there is a mental health crisis and the
left is only escalating it they they are
increasing this Mental Health crisis
rather than addressing it gender
dysphoria used to be something that you
went and got help for right and now it's
encouraged and it's pushed on our youth
uh you know what what an adult chooses
to do do it
um but when you are confusing our
children when you are sexualizing our
children that is where the line has to
be drawn
thank you
I'm Dave Rubin we are in Washington D.C
and joining me today is a U.S
congresswoman representing Colorado's
Third District congresswoman or Lauren
bobert welcome back to the Reuben report
Steve it is so great to be back in the
room and Report with you we were we were
supposed to do this yesterday yes
apparently even a congresswoman doesn't
have the power to stop Our Endless
Aviation problems in America oh no you
know Republicans are the majority so we
have a little more power but I'm not as
powerful as Tony Gonzalez
um who can shut down entire um border
security bills um just with the the
power of His words uh no I was stuck on
um in airports all day long uh I mean if
you're just going to count Eastern Time
8 A.M to midnight and I had two of my
boys with me which some people would
think that that causes for more stress
more of a headache but it was awesome I
had my 15 year old and my 10 year old
and we walked the airports together we
snuggled on airplanes we went and ate
good food in the airport they wanted
McDonald's vetoed that and said listen
you get McDonald's anytime you want but
uh you know it was really great just
spending the day with them and a unique
experience got home you know we got home
at 12 30. I put my 10 year old in the
shower I said I have been with you all
day you smell I made you shower before
we got on the airplane and I don't think
you used soap so we still didn't get fed
to bed till after 1am and you know do
you ever want to do that with some of
the Democrats here today
I don't think you use soap the mom
instincts come out in me you know
individual responsibility is usually not
their thing do your kids and family come
to DC often or is this just like you
doing your thing here in and out yeah so
I'm I'm pretty much on my own for the
most part but when there's when their
schedule allows it they certainly come
up here we pulled them out of school to
have weeks up here before because I had
been traveling so much and just missed
the heck out of them and said why don't
you come out here and they act like they
own DC when they come here they go
throughout the capital The Office
Buildings they know which members of
Congress have dogs in their office and
you know they they go and storm their
their our offices and hang out but this
is spring break so I have two boys with
me my oldest son is expecting his son
any day so yeah so he couldn't come too
deeply wait how old are you I'm 36.
you're gonna be a 36 year old grandma
yes yes I'm a Gigi Dave I'm a Gigi how
does that feel you know I'm really
excited
um so my mom she was 18 when she had me
I was 18 when I had Tyler and now he's
18 and one of his first comments to me
was Mom it's hereditary yeah I said nice
try uh it doesn't work that way
um but I'm really proud of him and um
and my grandson's mom for being
responsible because they could have
taken a different route and both of them
chose life and so it wasn't you know
anything I had to brow beat them with I
you know very calmly had the
conversation when we found out
um just let me know if you think
something else I just want to have a
talk with you if you decide to go a
different direction and both of them
um we're we're very excited and wanted
to move forward and welcome this life
into the world was there any part of
that that challenged any of your beliefs
before you did that sit down with them
and just realizing yeah so I mean
obviously I'm a Christian and you know
there there are standards that we like
to uphold but none of us do it perfectly
um you know one of the the biggest
things that I look to is him who knows
to do right and doesn't it's sin and I
mean there's things all throughout the
week that I know is right to do and
sometimes you know I I don't do them and
um you know so we can nitpick what the
Bible says as right and wrong but I
think just having that
um that that heart posture of wanting to
serve God and do the right thing is so
important and um I mean I I what I've
chose a different path of course you
know but
um this is where we're at and we're all
embracing it and we're so happy
um wait what do you mean you would have
chose a different path for Tyler for my
son yes yes
um so I mean I meaning at this age at
this age exactly yeah he wanted to go to
UTI in Florida he was going to graduate
and go to college in Florida and now you
know he's looking at petroleum
engineering classes courses at our
community college it's a great Community
College and rifle but you know I get to
have him home with me longer and you
know I get to be Gigi so certainly there
are some beliefs that you you know like
wait this isn't exactly right and
exactly what we have taught you but this
is where we're at and we're going to
teach you about Redemption and how to
move forward
um so I'm I'm happy that he's close to
me and I get to instruct him now on you
know how to be a loving father and and
how to raise a baby so let's do a couple
things about Colorado specifically and
then we'll get to the rest of the
country when I did my book tour back in
May I did Denver I'd stop in Denver and
I was shocked at the amount of homeless
people there like you expected in
Seattle you expected in San Francisco
and Portland Etc but I was shocked by
what was going on in Denver which is
such a gorgeous City and people are
great and all that so what is going on
in Denver Democrats
um so I mean really that's what happened
um we we had Universal mail-in ballots
um about 10 years ago go through and
Democrats started taking over every
single election and unfortunately it was
when um we had
um our gubernatorial race that elected
governor Jared Polis and after that is
when we just saw this dramatic decline
in in Colorado are our policies
infringing on coloradans rights um and
and then just the crime increase
marijuana it's legal in Colorado
obviously and I think that that did
bring in a different reconnect that
directly because as a general rule a
more libertarian and I do believe in
legalizing this stuff and I'm not
against people doing what they want with
their lives but even seeing in New York
what's going on right now the whole city
just smells like weed basically yes you
you can't go outside in Denver and not
smell weed and it's pretty much
throughout most of the state especially
in those urban areas but I think it just
brought with it
um that legalization brought with it a
different population and and certainly a
transient population
um and the homelessness has just
skyrocketed in Denver when we were
having
um the the all the covid lockdowns and
everything I mean we just had any
complete encampment right there at the
Denver Capitol yeah I mean like literal
tent cities everywhere I was shocked yes
um and they are everywhere and they're
they're not doing anything to remove
them so they're enabling the problem and
it is only increasing what do you think
of well I guess I know what you think
but so polis it seems to me that people
say when I'm always like oh there's no
moderate Democrat people are like well
paulus is kind of he's not completely
insane but it doesn't sound like the
policies are that far from what right no
the policies are very extreme and I do
like Governor Jared Polis on a personal
level I mean we've had some interaction
and he's been very kind to me but his
policies do not match that moderate or
libertarian Mantra that people have
about him even even hearing stories of
him serving in the House of
Representatives is very different than
what I'm seeing as him being our
governor and maybe it's his cabinet
members who are pushing these extreme
policies and he's kind of going along
with it there is a super majority the
Democrats have a super majority in
Colorado and the state legislature
pushes extreme policies and
unfortunately those get signed into laws
into law whether that's gun control laws
or comprehensive sex ed or vaccine
mandates for our our children in order
to be to to go to school and so all of
this is so extreme and from from the top
down it affects everyone everywhere the
lockdowns affected our businesses uh so
many were shut down our churches were
shut down our school schools were shut
down people were masked up and and just
lost so so much we didn't have a
Statewide vaccine mandate for the covid
vaccine and maybe that's why people look
and say oh look he wasn't that bad right
um but I in that circumstance I kind of
see it like as an abused spouse like oh
he doesn't beat me all the time you know
we have good days right because I'm
telling you I mean his name is on that
very short list of like not insane
Democrats and I would love to interview
him and discuss some of this stuff so we
shall see I think you should interview
him and like I said like he and I have
had great conversations together I've
brought him to um he he came into my
Washington DC office and we talked about
water and it was a very productive
conversation that we had about water
Colorado doesn't have a lack of that
resource we have an over allocation
problem and so he and I are trying to
work together to see how we can store
more of that water it's a low-hanging
fruit and you just came from California
well California takes a lot of our water
and
um it's really frustrating when you see
hundreds of billions of gallons of water
being dumped into the ocean rather than
stored in California after we sent that
precious resource Downriver do you sense
that Colorado is going to just sort of
have what what now although Colorado I
think is somewhat purple it's going to
have what the blue states have which is
that the big cities so mostly Denver
will just go increasingly blue and the
rural areas will just go increasingly
red and then we'll just have that
non-stopped engine yes um so I do see
increasingly blue but our red areas I do
think that those are turning more purple
I mean look at my race I won by 546
votes our oil and gas industry is gone
we've been regulated into poverty in in
our communities the Colorado's Third
District no longer has that industry
like we did and those companies have
left they've taken with them their
employees and their families and it has
impacted us dramatically and I have all
of the tourists towns most of the
tourist towns in my district I have
Telluride I've Aspen I've Glenwood
Springs we just had redistricting but I
used to have Steamboat Springs and with
your ray but Californians are moving
into those areas and they're able to
afford it that the taxes are cheaper in
Colorado than they were in California so
they're like this is great but they're
taking their policies from California
and bringing them to Colorado yeah so
are you seeing that for sure because
it's really interesting what I've
noticed is the people that are coming to
Florida and where I live in the suburbs
of Miami like it's all new people and
but they get it they really do get it
everyone like you can feel it like no
I'm here to keep Florida free I wear my
Florida hat so all the all the ogs know
that I'm cool like but do you sense that
it's a different type really that's
coming to Colorado that kind of makes
sense in a way yes people are not coming
to Colorado for Freedom uh they're
coming to Colorado for a lifestyle that
they're accustomed to and and even
policies
um that they have voted for in the past
but they don't recognize that they
failed them them and that's why they're
leaving so they think oh if we try a new
form of Socialism right
um this this type hasn't been tried yet
so we'll try it over here in this state
socialism with snow right
socialism with snow and so unfortunately
um it's not the same as Florida Florida
is doing amazing uh and I mean I I'm
envious of how great Florida is doing
you have America's governor and uh we I
we are just getting more and more blue
more and more liberal and these extreme
policies
um red flag laws um we we were at the
top of the list to get red flag laws and
now our state legislature is wanting to
increase those or wanting to ban
um any kind of firearm with a detachable
magazine I mean first we start off with
high capacity magazine bands in 2013 and
now it's we want to ban all firearms
that have a detachable magazine uh it's
just as as Extreme as you can imagine
and I'm doing everything that I can to
bring awareness to it show people hey
your votes matter we have the government
that we deserve we have to be engaged we
have to be involved and uh and then
certainly help to strengthen Colorado's
Third District so we're not 546 votes
away from an election right I was gonna
say Colorado was it 546 votes yeah how
long did it take it was like a full oh
gosh oh and it was longer than that um
it was in December when we had the final
count I was the last Republicans race to
be called uh so we we had um we had one
it was an automatic recount and so we
had to go and cure ballots um and so if
if a ballot was rejected because of
their signature we were able to contact
that voter and get it corrected we cured
about 700 ballots and then won by 546.
so that entire effort
um to cure those ballots every single
one of them mattered man those go the
wrong way you could end it up in Florida
they could have yes all right on a less
humorous note for a moment let's just so
we're taping this on Tuesday obviously
there was the this shooting in Tennessee
yesterday
um we're gonna post this on Thursday so
some of this may may move a little bit
some of the information we find
the basics of what I could see was was
the way it's just how everything is
framed in this crazy media lens like now
it sounds like this was a biological
woman girl who I guess identified as a
male or at least used male pronouns this
is going to cause the anti-gun people to
go for the guns it's going to cause the
people who are pissed about the woke
stuff to go after the trans people like
is there any way to have a conversation
about this in in the same way can we can
we just put personal responsibility on
people and and say this was a terrible
person who did a terrible thing
um I I mean I I do think that we have a
mental crisis here in a mental health
crisis in the United States that's
that's being
um that's growing and really being
encouraged uh but I I don't want to go
after an entire group of people for
something that one person did
um just like the left goes after you
know all gun owners when when something
like this happens look I'm from Colorado
we're at the epicenter of you know these
school shootings and it's absolutely
terrible but you don't disarm
law-abiding citizens because of One Nut
Job who did a horrible heinous act
um and so also looking at Nashville who
stopped this crazed shooter a good guy
with a gun and so I mean this is um this
has to be something that we focus on I
was actually just in a Committee hearing
um and and let me say I I was in the
airport yesterday you know when I when
this broke and my boys and I prayed
together uh just the families and
everyone affected and you know I I know
the left goes after that oh we don't
want your thoughts and prayers and this
and that but I mean I believe in prayer
and that works and I I know the power of
the wraparound presence of the Holy
Spirit and how he can just comfort and
heal broken hearts and so I mean that's
something that that we did together when
we heard about this and
um uh but but there's so much I was in
the Committee hearing
um on the ATF rule with with the pistol
brace and I actually got completely
sidetracked because I wanted to say
something that I had said in years past
and used to believe
um I wanted to start off and say we
don't differ in our hearts we differ in
data but I stopped myself and he said no
we do differ in our hearts because
I I don't want any child killed and
they're talking about this as the
leading cause of of death for for our
youth is gun violence they said no I'm
not even close actually it's abortion
you know we we're aborting nearly one
New Meme that they're using constantly
now I haven't seen that one yet well
that is non-violent oh yes yes yes but
yeah I mean we're up to I mean nearly a
million a year and that's never
discussed
um and so we do differ in our hearts
because every life is valuable uh that's
why I'm so proud of my son and and his
girlfriend for for choosing life
um even in
um if you look at rural and urban areas
the teen pregnancy rate isn't much
different but the teen abortion rate is
much higher in urban areas than it is in
rural areas because we value life we we
care about that and do have personal
responsibility so we want to look at
data and see what we can do to protect
life and I want to arm teachers I want
to have secure schools there was an idea
I proposed in the last Congress to take
some of the unspent coveted money and
secure schools protect our children we
protect congress with with fences and
miles of razor wire and tens of
thousands of armed National Guards
because walls work and armed security
Works uh we we secure our airports we
secure our banks why not our most
precious asset are children let me ask
you about the arming teachers thing
because I'm not there's part of me
that's not inherently against it but
then when you see how many teachers
are actually left-wing activists how
many teachers are actually teaching this
woke craziness how many teachers are
clearly not good at their job or or
actually quite negligent in their
responsibilities what do you do about
that because it's not as if you're just
going to hand gun some people train them
and they're going to be ideologically
lined up with you in a way that's going
to make any sort of sense correct well I
don't think um most of those woke
teachers are are going to be
volunteering to be armed
um you know there's there's certainly
circumstances
um that are are always beyond my
imagination
um but in Colorado we actually have
um a law that allows teachers to be
armed it's up to the school board if the
school board says teachers can be
certified then they go through the
certification and we have an
organization faster Colorado that trains
teachers
um and it's a very extensive tactical
training course
um that they're that they're taught how
to be responsible with this firearm most
have had experience you have retired
military Personnel retired law
enforcement and I I think that having
some presence there able to defend the
students is a really good thing it
doesn't have to be every teacher it
doesn't have to be the majority of
teachers but even knowing
um that there is someone there to stop
and an imminent threat I think that is a
large enough deterrent because even
we're hearing reports I don't know how
true they are but we're hearing reports
that the shooter in Nashville whom I
won't name nor give pronouns
um said this was a soft target like this
person knew that this school was was not
going to be able to stop the shooting
so at what point though I know you don't
want to blame groups and I think that's
important I literally didn't tweet about
it yesterday because I was just like I
just don't want to add in the midst of
the craziness no everyone gets in on it
for clicks and all that stuff but at
what point do you think the Democrat
rhetoric and this is what they do to you
guys all the time but the Republicans
are always defending guns and it's their
fault so I don't want to do that same
thing but at what point when you
constantly tell this group of people
that they're oppressed that there's a
trans genocide that you know all of this
stuff that is just patently untrue at
what point do you have to look at your
colleagues and be like do you see there
there is a problem here you actually are
radicalizing a certain set of people
right no I I do think that that's true
and that is something that we need to
speak of just this one particular
instance I don't want to blame all of
the people but yes there is a mental
health crisis and the left is only
escalating it
um they they are increasing this Mental
Health crisis rather than addressing it
gender dysphoria used to be something
that you went and got help for right and
now it's encouraged and it's pushed on
our youth uh you know what what an adult
chooses to do do it
um but when you are confusing our
children when you are sexualizing our
children that is where the line has to
be drawn when you are telling elementary
students three-year-olds five-year-olds
you could be a boy you could be a girl
well they could be a mermaid I wanted to
be a mermaid when I was four you know I
lived in the pool and you know
Decepticon right Decepticon yeah so I I
mean this this is a problem and it is
radicalizing
um a group we even saw or I saw a CNN
article that says if you've ever tweeted
a meme of a black woman well then that's
digital black face face this is the new
oppress me of the day you know oppress
me please and you know when you're when
you're telling someone you're not good
enough you are oppressed you are the
Lesser person you are the Lesser class
well and that's going to get in in
inside of them and cause depression and
and more mental health crises so it is
it is something that I believe that the
left is um radicalizing and encouraging
so what do you do to reach across the
eye on this because I'm doing about 10
or 12 interviews all with Republicans
when I'm here we reached out to
Democrats not one responded and I spoke
to Senator Ron Johnson yesterday he
basically said well none of the
Democrats will talk to me I spoke to
Crenshaw and he said well kind of on the
DL they'll talk to him and some of them
aren't that crazy uh Gates gave me a
similar version to that
who are the Not Crazy Ones do they talk
to you and is there anything that can be
done with them I mean if I'm too scary
of an interview for them it's like I'm
not known for the the hardball interview
I try to listen to people yes you do and
but they won't sit here exactly yeah yes
well I mean that's the problem because
the Democrat Party has their marching
orders
um we saw it during the speaker's race
everyone's yelling at the Republicans
saying you have to get unified you this
looks crazy well we have independent
thought the Democrats were told what to
do and they did exactly what they were
told to do right in the radicals like
even even the radicals absolutely and
even the Congress before that you know
that they had they were forming a coup
to take down Nancy Pelosi and they took
the deal
um they said you know what my committee
assignment's good enough thank you ma'am
and walked on
um and so
um in so much of this they don't want to
engage
um we see it in debate uh they want to
say their side and leave uh they don't
want to hear the opposing views a lot of
times if I'm debating on the house floor
I'll go early I'll hear what the
Democrats have to say my colleagues have
to say I'll stay later
sometimes I even ask somebody for their
time so I could go up and respond right
but does anyone else do that I feel like
nobody listens to the talks like someone
gets up there talking they're like
nobody's there but it's on C-Span or we
see the clips it is very rare um because
you do have your scheduled times and our
days are really busy here so I
understand it
um but usually you go in for your two
minutes that's what you have to speak
maybe it's five minutes and and then you
get out and you're on to the next
meeting and it's almost feels like it's
by Design
um to keep us so busy that we can't
engage with our with our colleagues and
back to the speakers race that was one
of my favorite Parts about it those four
days we were all together on the house
floor debating engaging in conversations
with our colleagues I talked to
Republicans I had never spoke to before
I talked to Democrats I had never spoke
to before and it was a wonderful four
days of actually getting to know and
understand one another were you worried
that I mean you were you know ultimately
you guys got some concessions but you
were you worried as one of the most
outspoken people people sort of against
McCarthy that you were going to pay a
price just personally even absolutely
but but that wasn't going to be what
determined
um what I was doing I I couldn't say you
know oh I'm never going to be re-elected
again if that's my only thought is my
next election then I have no business
being here I need to do what I believe
is right that's what I was sent here to
do I convinced and promised what
hundreds of thousands of people that I'm
a leader that I'm strong I'm principled
I'm going to stand for them and fight
for them and so I wasn't going to sit
back and go along to get along and say
oh my committee assignment oh I don't
want a primary I don't want you know
leadership spending money against me in
a race or you know any kind of
repercussions whatever you could think
of I knew to do what was right and um
and and this was all about these
negotiations that we had started in the
summer and in good faith and I'm glad
that speaker McCarthy saw the Merit and
what we were asking for and and gave
them to us
um I want to use more of the tools that
we've received and some of them it's
just not time for them yet like the
Holmen rule that'll come up more in
Appropriations uh but I don't want to
only admire what we've received I want
to put these tools to work I'm
interviewing him later today at the
Capitol is there anything I can push him
on for you you know anything you need a
little nudge on I actually think so
because I like the fact that he seems
like he's coming alive with this stuff
he really does I think speaker McCarthy
is doing a really great job and I'm not
just saying that I I he is very
aggressive on this even the January 6
videos that he released that wasn't part
of the concessions that was a bonus
um you know and so this is amazing um if
there's anything that I want to be more
aggressive on it's subpoenas
um we we had um and this isn't anything
against
um chairman comer or or Pat Fallon who's
a subcommittee chair and the
subcommittee we have the ATF hearing we
had an ATF hearing without the ATF
um I want the ATF in and they are coming
in April but um I want to start issuing
these subpoenas and being very
aggressive with it hats are so I'm glad
you mentioned that because uh you were
part of the Twitter hearings and there
was a great viral moment where you
basically were like you guys did this to
me like you did it to me and I'm a
congresswoman yeah and this is what I've
asked everyone else who has sat here
over the last couple days what actually
comes of this stuff other than okay we
can expose some of it so you bring out a
Twitter executive he kind of did some
bad stuff sort of sometimes did some
decent stuff but what about the
government side of it like when are we
when are we gonna drag or when are you
guys going to drag out the government
agents who actually were communicating
with them as opposed to the Twitter guys
who it's not that I have sympathy for
them but they're private employees who
were probably in over their head and
whatever yes and so we did have um
a former FBI agent Baker that was that
was in there but but he was working for
Twitter correct we do need to bring in
these people
um but we called those hearings um
Twitter file hearings part one so we are
going to have more
um but unfortunately Dave I do think
that these next two years are two years
of exposure
um and I want to expose the the federal
employees who are involved in this more
than anything
um and then um hopefully the inspectors
generals look at this and there's some
sort of referral
um that we we can actually get criminal
referrals for for some of the things
that have been done but I don't know if
we can do that in this Administration
right so basically you need a republican
Administration to actually do anything
so the hope is you can get people to
know enough about it right well all the
top guys are Biden's guys right now
um so that that is our biggest struggle
so we have to build this case we have to
expose what's been hidden from the
American people for years there has been
no oversight in the House of
Representatives and there still isn't
much over site in the Senate the
Democrats have the gavel there and they
aren't going to bring in serious people
to have this oversight so it's our job
to carry the weight of the house and the
Senate and make up for those years where
there was no oversight conducted not to
beat a dead horse but were there any
Democrats on that in that hearing that
we're like oh actually even though I'm a
Democrat and they were mostly going
after conservatives this is a violation
of the First Amendment maybe like even
on the DL Did anyone say you know if
there were
um I didn't hear of it and so everything
was extreme Mega Republicans and you
know I did set the record straight and
said listen we are not extreme Mega
Republicans it is ultra Maga
but we were exposing how um you know the
federal government worked with Twitter
to suppress the hunter Biden laptop
story they didn't want to touch that
they everything is January 6 and they're
they're using what they know works
because it did work for them in the last
election but now we're closing what
happened during January 6th what
happened with the censorship what
happened with the lockdowns the fraud
the waste abuse with the covid funds and
Afghanistan other committees are having
hearings on that we we had a soldier
that had the bomber
um the suicide bomber in his sights and
he was not allowed to neutralize that
threat in his sights and now we have 13
of our soldiers killed I I mean
absolutely disgusting but we are
exposing what was going on and the
American people are going to see it and
um I hope in the next
um two to four years we have actual
accountability I don't want any show
Pony hearings like Benghazi I want
people to be held accountable and so do
the American people do you think it's
kind of funny when Biden keeps saying
you know the the extreme Mega
Republicans or ultramag or whatever like
he's sort of talking about your wing of
the thing as if you guys are completely
running the show and the whole point is
that you guys were on the outside and
had to fight for a lot of that but he's
he's basically trying to paint everybody
as if you you and Matt and Gates and a
couple other people if they want us to
run the show let's run it because we
have some really great ideas
um I mean look at even the debt ceiling
proposal um it was the house Freedom
caucus that came out and said we have a
plan uh we aren't going to default on
our nation's debt but we're going to
claw back some of this stuff some of the
unspent coveted funding the um the
Student Loan program we're taking that
back you know I mean if you want to just
do Pennies on the dollar we're not
building your 500 million dollar FBI
um building that you that you need that
your brand new building uh and so
there's a lot of the things they're
going for the FBI needs a 500 million
dollar building yeah you know really
important uh that gosh uh so there there
are things that we can absolutely they
work so hard
you know it was really it was really The
Raid you know like they're like hey we
need a bonus you know after this
Mar-A-Lago raid
um so uh we have a plan Joe Biden's plan
uh it increases taxes on everyone
um they are doing nothing to reduce
inflation to increase energy development
um everything that they're doing will
increase inflation and reduce energy we
have 20 million Americans that can't pay
afford their utility bills right now we
have a wide open Southern border we want
it secure we want the flow of fentanyl
to stop and so we have a plan and I I
told Joe in our press conference I said
we're meeting tonight on the hill you
want to come here put down your ice
cream join us we'll have a conversation
and uh you know it's funny the guy keeps
coming downstairs and says the only
reason I'm down here for ice cream and
I'm starting to believe it like that's
the only reason he's coming downstairs
like I like ice cream yeah and
everybody's like oh there's the old man
who likes ice cream exactly well we hear
about the horrible tragedy in Nashville
and he says I hear there's chocolate
chip chip cookies that's why we did like
a five minute stand-up routine about ice
cream when he came down it was nuts all
right let me ask you one more I know you
hit the gym before you got here you got
a long day of stuff you got to get out
of here one more for you
so you talked about what's going to
happen in two years hopefully obviously
this thing seems to be like going back
and forth between the Trump to Santa's
thing I know you love uh Trump you are
obviously said some nice things about
the Santas here I think you have a sense
of where I'm at on this thing what's
your general take and and actually do
you think there is a way which would be
my preference that it doesn't have to
end up in destruction of one or or both
yeah that would be the best way but I
just don't know if it's positive correct
I I at this point I don't know if it's
possible either I think there's room in
this tent for both of both president
Trump and uh Governor Ron DeSantis
um I I would I would love for this to
not end ugly um I have endorsed
president Trump I do endorse president
Trump I I believe that he will be our
nominee
um obviously Governor DeSantis has not
announced that he's running at this time
but I mean even the way the left is
still going after president Trump with
with the D.A in New York uh they do not
want him to run because they know that
he will win and I mean think about it
they're not going after Nikki Haley you
know she's she's a member of the club
she's she's paid her dues they're not
worried about her uh but they are going
after president Trump still they have
not left this man or his family alone at
all and you know I think Governor
DeSantis has great potential to be
president of the United States I just
wanted to wait till 2028.
any final thoughts or should we end on
that that seems pretty that's pretty
clear I love president Trump and
Governor DeSantis you just keep Florida
strong for a while well the funny thing
is for me I'm like look if Trump ends up
the president and the Santa stays
Governor like yeah are you freaking
thrilled I'll be thrilled if DeSantis is
the president it's like that's why I
just don't want the mutually assured
destruction right that seems like it's
on the way yes so we shall see we shall
see good luck for the rest of the day
I'll try to nudge McCarthy for you
thanks yes let's get some subpoenas
we've issued tens so far let's make it
hundreds
thanks Dave if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell